[Music]
welcome back to cbs mornings we are very
excited to launch a new series with you
it's called mornings in the metaverse
we'll be exploring what many in the tech
world say is the next big thing and i
happen to agree you'll be able to
immerse yourself in the internet perhaps
sitting at a virtual office
heading out to enjoy the virtual beach
now you've seen the headlines we all
have microsoft is spending nearly 70
billion dollars to acquire a gaming
company that can help it build virtual
worlds
apple for its part is reportedly
developing a new mixed reality headset
and then there's facebook which changed
its corporate name to meta in a nod to
what it sees as the future so to find
out where we are going we decided to
take a look back at where we've been
from dialing into the internet to
bringing it everywhere we go that's
right now
the next big leap may be living inside
of it
once upon a time reporters got their
first real glimpse of the world wide web
that thing called the internet
the special world created when phone
lines connect computers to each other
hi guys it was the 1990s
[Music]
and as we started with the very basics
all web addresses start with http colon
double backslash the whole concept was
still kind of baffling and what about
this internet thing do you know anything
about that sure
what what the hell is that exactly well
david what it was was a revolution the
internet upended almost every aspect of
our lives especially when we figured out
how to take it with us and i can just
scroll around like this and scroll over
here and i can even make this text
bigger if i want to and now if you
believe the hype a new revolution is
here the next platform and medium will
be even more immersive an embodied
internet where you're in the experience
not just looking at it and we call this
the metaverse facebook microsoft apple
and so many others are investing
billions in what may become a single 3d
virtual world
or maybe several worlds connected or
maybe not no one is quite sure
except to say that you'll hopefully want
to spend a lot of time
and money there
oh there's swag
so to get a sense of what the metaverse
is so far here we go i visited an
existing piece of it so this is my vr
self or at least my avatar did there he
is
it's pretty seamless
you know i don't have arms or legs but
got hair
nice to meet you thank you we wanted to
chat with people on a social platform
called alt space vr which is made by
microsoft and accessed through our
facebook headset hello
how are you
we found that just like in real life
could i ask you a couple questions some
people did not feel like talking maybe
nope you poured it away from me but
among those who did
why are you here you know just by
curiosity we met people from all over
the world all of them coming together in
what at times did indeed feel like
genuine human contact
right now i'm in oaxaca mexico and we
are
literally our consciousness is in the
same room right now having a
conversation so when people say
where are you in the real world
you consider the answer to be both the
physical world of oaxaca and this
virtual space that we are sharing
correct they're both virtual reality and
physical reality they're both reality
it's funny because we'll have this
moment where we all hang out i'll still
implant this as a memory of you and i
hanging out together you know even
though you're a cartoon character we are
still a long way from the future that
hollywood envisioned
with blended reality projected in front
of our eyes a place called
the oasis
or a seamless virtual world providing an
escape from our own miserable existence
and yet
people say oh my god it's a dystopia
we're going to be spending hours a day
inside these virtual worlds far from
nature i don't know about you but i
already spent most of my day inside
david chalmers is a philosophy professor
at new york university and the author of
the book reality plus virtual worlds and
the problems of philosophy
in it he argues that the virtual world
has the potential to be a meaningful one
the very word virtual to me is a marker
of okay the meaningful stuff has ended
and now this is play time or different
the meaning that we find in the physical
world comes from us
we invest a physical world with meaning
and i think we can do the same to a
digital world yeah okay it's all made of
a bunch of bits well the physical world
is made of a bunch of atoms meaning
comes where we find it in the metaverse
you'll be able to teleport not just to
any place but any time as well
what really worries chalmers is more of
a timeless question about the
concentration of power in the hands of a
select few in this metaverse world
created by these companies
and it sounds ridiculous but i'll ask it
would that make the ceos the mark
zuckerbergs the tim cooks in essence god
of those places three of the traditional
properties of god creator all-powerful
all-knowing on the other hand they may
not have other traditional properties of
god for example will they be all good or
all wise
almost certainly not this is one of the
reasons why we have to worry
about who it is that creates and
controls our virtual worlds for now hey
we're shaking hands in the metaverse
that's great nice to meet you tony we
saw the real potential in this virtual
world when we ran into frankie coatier a
semi truck driver from florida he was
sitting in his rig at a truck stop in
ohio you're in a semi truck right now
correct and talking to us outside a
concert venue in old space vr
wherever that is
hands out beats tic toc
facebook any social media platform so
this is the next step
and yet the future of any virtual world
depends on how it stacks up to this one
you can't touch you can't taste i mean
some of the greatest experiences in this
world are not duplicatable in that one
absolutely that's true yeah so is the
thought that the metaverse eventually
will port all of our experiences and
senses in this world into it so it'll be
equivalent i think in the very long term
we can imagine a metaverse that brings
in not just sight and sound but you know
the body as well until that day comes
it's hard to imagine how our experiences
in the virtual world even those
experiences of a multi-billionaire like
mark zuckerberg all right here we go
could ever really compare
to the real thing
i love the video of him doing that by
the way i love that video i think that's
very cool i think he makes a great point
about how like uh the real world this
world still has a lot going for it it
looked really fun so what i'm still
trying i'm still struggling with this
what are the advantages of going to the
metaverse and can you only get there
using those you can only get there
through the headset and the first thing
i'll say is and we can't there's no way
to communicate this other than to just
say it when you put that headset on your
brain really is tricked right you may be
sitting in your living room but you
mentally and psychologically feel like
you are somewhere else and you were
meeting those people like those people
the cartoon characters i feel like i had
an exchange i do think that's true it
really happened a couple of times i've
done so because we're building a new
world where there aren't scarce
resources we can make as much of
anything as we want ideally it'd be a
kind of utopia but but the income won't
matter class won't matter background
won't matter well first of all you have
to be able to actually afford and own
this technology so if you're in a poor
country i can see a world where there
are no stakes because everybody's living
virtually in rich and wealthy countries
and for the rest of the world they're
living the reality which is the reality
of life that that is also a concern but
i don't think the stakes
he pointed it out that you can't taste
anything in the virtual world you can't
bleed in the virtual world you can't
fall someone might say you might fall in
love in the virtual world that ain't
love that's something else
love really what you're looking for
everything i love life i want to
experience all of life you can be real
dinner in the virtual world you can be
all those things in the virtual world
and
if we make it a public resource in part
at least then everyone will be able to
access it